afin de rentrer du delaware et de
philadelphie hier soir ghislaine
mailloux et son conjoint françois lui
aussi camionneurs s'apprête à repartir
pour une autre livraison en floride
appartement barbecue campingaz j'en ai
des specs j'ai emmené jerry cas j'ai
acheté incarne car avec la fermeture des
restaurants et des haltes routières
depuis le début de la crise les
camionneurs restent confinés dans leurs
véhicules pour éviter les contacts
extérieurs gta les faits montrent chacun
des clients gérés stella montreuil en
avant dans un convoi la paix comme les
camionneurs l'appelle la niche est
vraiment dans son camion long de plus de
22 m elle s'adapte à la nouvelle réalité
de lakovic 19 g du curé à lantriac gdb
b8 nappe
on prend les matches de rang la place
des réunions la blache shifter on se
lave les mains
pour les deux prochains jours
elle et son conjoint vont se relayer 24
heures sur 24 pour rouler plus de 4400
km aller-retour avec la dernière nage
j'allais vraiment trop sur quatre c'est
vraiment le métier que je me suis le
plus utile
mais sur la longue route face à la peur
du virus
les haltes routières ferme où sont dans
un piteux état
avec en art à part ça on va essayer
d'aller chercher un café
lauret est profitable et le café
disponible pour une fois est parti
dimanche pays survenue mercredi
j'ai pas lu axa rit on nous bloque par
tous les deux sont durs d'accès manger
convenablement et dur
halle aux toiles est apte à ses allées
et venues entre le canada et les
états-unis se multiplient face à la
pression de ravitailler les supermarchés
et les commerces est essentielle ils
sont exemptés de l'obligation de se
mettre en quarantaine mais jusqu'où ça
va aller on ne sait pas de jour en jour
des directives du gouvernement change
une cadence infernale parfois difficile
à gérer
bah on est plus propre et c est ce que
ça vous fait peur
oui
oui parce que je n'ai par action
tangible
j'étais petit j'ai deux petites filles
j'ai des enfants
c'est pour ça que je la chine ou qui
reviennent mon voyage l'autre bord son
camion donc c'est sa chambre à au moins
c'est mon un doublé baird manon
l'utilisent pour mettre notre stock de
cannes et deux dans le camion se cuisine
et même parfois davantage aux utiliser
chaque petit coup moins connus dans le
camion l'eau pour être confortable y
avoir qu est ce que ça nous prend l'eau
la toile est dans sa caution n'a pas de
toilettes portatives chimiques y en a
partout alerte avec
doblas à capvern cette crise du
coronavirus permettra-t-elle de
reconnaître les camionneurs à leur juste
valeur
on est des héros mais on va retenir des
héros les reconnaître comme
professionnel c'est que il y aurait des
leur statut ne serait valorisée
l'amélioration des rémunérations
l'amélioration dé la régularisation si
vous voulez des arts de travail leur
permettent de passer plus de temps en
famille leur permettre d'avoir un mode
de vie un peu plus normale
pour l'instant la cadence est loin de
ralentir pour ghislaine et son conjoint
dès le retour de floride ils devront à
nouveau reprendre la route direction le
midwest après quelques heures de repos
pas de problème pour eux ils sont fiers
que leur travail soit décidément plus
que jamais un service essentiel